Todd is with us in Boise Idaho hi Todd
how are you good Dave how are you doing
today
better than I deserve what's your net
worth sir a little over 2.8 million
okay and and what's that invested in we
have four or five hundred thousand in
401ks and IRAs there's a couple hundred
thousand in cash and we have a analysis
okay so real estates the most of it by
far by far and then like a million and
mutual funds give or take okay cool and
how much of that did you inherit zero
okay how old are you
48 okay and during your working lifetime
what's been your average annual income
probably between 100 120 okay all right
and what's your career been I pretty
much have owned my own businesses doing
what anything in particular I lived in
Las Vegas for many years I used to make
dice clocks and the last ten years have
been making metal stamps she'd been
manufacturing and owned your own
business and a lot of different things
okay
yep my entire life my wife is an
accountant she's a CPA okay all right
cool what's your degree in
I have no degree but my wife like I said
there's an accountant and that she had a
4.0 okay all right cool and before you
were wealthy how many brand-new cars did
you build buy brand new 0 0 you buy you
cents in the last three we have bought
but only since we had the money to do it
yeah you got plenty of money you're in
good shape
what's the most expensive pair of jeans
you always bought you ever bought no $25
okay and what part has generosity played
in your wealth building plays a great
deal part I would try to give all our
giving to the family to people that we
know um people that need help
mm-hmm okay and of course a home how
much debt have you used to build the
wealth zero well you bought a lot of
real estate you pay cash for a limit
every single one we paid cash as we got
it oh wow okay all right Wow so you
started with nothing you don't have a
degree and you end up with 2.8 million
dollars at 48 years old
what are you Terran owning your own
business and you obviously have a knack
for not only operating a business but
for the particular areas of business
you've chosen to go into you're
obviously good at it so what do you tell
people that are listening that's the 25
year old version of you that's walking
around with their lips stuck out saying
they can't do this you can't get ahead
in America today how did you do this if
they wanted to be like you how would
they do it the first step was my wife
and I we we had to get on the same page
financially once we did that then we
could pretty much overcome anything
mm-hmm and from there on out it was work
your butt off work seven days a week
mm-hmm save you money if that's your
money and don't waste it yeah I mean I
don't drive by that save your money
invest your money because you you've got
like two million dollars in real estate
yeah I mean you didn't dump it all back
into the business you didn't go spending
it on whatever you bought real estate
when you made money right yes is that
phase we made with buy another house and
we have seven Reynolds and then we have
three homes and one of the homes that we
left our in-laws live in in Vegas you
know they have some medical issues and
they're having some hard time so we let
them move in the house and they get to
live there rent-free yeah well you can
afford that yeah yeah so you're in a
position to help family yeah yes we try
together and give it home good for you
so your recommendation to the 25-year
old version of you is what is that work
hard keep your nose down and save your
money it's pretty simple isn't it cuz
you didn't hit you didn't hit the
lottery and you didn't nobody came
around and just handed your money
anywhere did they no sir not at all
man fact uh this is our 30 year
anniversary for my wife and I and we
both retired this year
well congratulations Todd your great
American success story I'm honored to
speak with you sir thank you David thank
you for your service thank you for your
time